you know what kind of leverage that is
you know how nice that feels
i want that for you
and i know how to get there
and i've seen it 100 times and i know
exactly what it doesn't look like
and it doesn't look like when you don't
know how to scale marketing
sales
is just bad marketing
you got your perspective
[Applause]
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
from that second
to me being right here with my natural
dna and how i watched my dad's business
for those especially those four high
school years where i didn't have a lot
of say so i had to listen and watch more
than talk or get things done
i purely watched what defense negativity
and not trusting in building a family
looks like
the amount of money my dad left on the
table because unfortunately he was
raised in an environment where he didn't
know how to trust
was devastating
he would
created a framework where everything was
based on fear when i think about the
size of the businesses in this room and
i think about the human dynamics and the
consumer dynamics that really drive
where your range is from your business
there's only two versions of where
you're going to go with your business
you're either going to play prevent
defense
or try to be the 85 bears if you're a
football fan and play defense
or you're going to go pure offense
right there was a very famous college
basketball team in the late 80s early
90s called loyola mariemont
maybe for some of you fans remember
there's a tragic death of hank gathers a
very famous player on the court
but the reason i bring it up is not to
remember that tough memory the reason i
bring it up is that
college basketball team used to win
games 142 to 126. they had a run and gun
system
and
i think about it a lot because it's how
i run my business
when i tell you the amount of mistakes
that i make
it's stunning and staggering i'm a human
being i'm making 100 decisions a day
when i tell you that the amount of time
i dwell or even give it a second thought
is almost non-existent
when i think about small businesses and
that's what we all are including
vaynermedia for me
there really isn't anything but people
when i think about this room and what
you do for a living you're selling
people
when i sold wine i had to taste those
wines which was a pretty good gig for a
while
but i was selling wine i had people but
i was selling wine
vayner x my holding company of agency
right now is 1500 people globally right
singapore
mexico city
la new york london
all we're doing is we're selling people
right and ours is a little bit different
in that your business model is really
fascinating and i've always liked it
because the reality is
if you can figure it out right and
create the right flexes it can be quite
profitable
right because you're carrying a certain
amount of people i mean i always think
about if i did this business i'd be like
you're really in the business of like
just holding your breath every second
hoping that if you've got 200 or 100
clients that six don't have an issue at
the same exact time and it's just right
it's not super hard to understand what
you're dealing with but what that speaks
to and i think about allah and i've had
a couple friends through the years be in
this business
and i i've always been fascinated
because i think the business inherently
is
spending way too much time on defense
what if this happens
what if what if and i think a lot about
what happens to a business like this
that goes on pure offense and what
triggers can be created with staff
and partnerships and other variables
that can scale
so that you feel comfortable in selling
in front of the inevitable opportunities
or the vulnerabilities that come along
with having that many clients with the
potential of needing servicing and
things of that nature
i think there's several things that run
through my mind here today first of all
probably the thing i want to spend the
most amount of time on
which is
this concept of
carrying people on your team
because they've just been around for a
long time
and this one is emotional because some
of this
started as your actual friend or family
became your actual friend because you've
been working together for six seven nine
twelve years
i think
a lot about this issue um at this level
which is the notion of how much value
comes
with actually cutting or limiting the
bottom 20
of people
in your organization
right so notice what i said there in a
sentence cutting or limiting
i have worked with family and friends my
whole life i have started every business
with family and friends i love it i
think it's a good idea
it's a bad idea for most people because
they care about money more than
happiness and their friends
starting a business with friends or
family is a bad idea if you care about
money
because it will always get to a place
eventually where there's friction
starting a business with family and
friends if you're a little more chill
about money
and you love business because you love
the game not the money is a tremendous
idea
so that's that starts the first question
that you're really going through right
second
is if you're in a position where
you've got long-term employees and
actually let me phrase it a little bit
different if you're sitting right now
and thinking as we're talking about your
situation
if your number one value prop
of the people you're thinking about
right now
is that they're loyal and reliable but
you've got a big problem
if your number one value prop
of the people you're thinking about on
your team is that they're loyal and
reliable but
you've got a problem because if the butt
is that there's a lot of other things
that they don't do well
if the butt is that they make a lot of
other people within the organization not
feel good
you've got a major problem
what you're really in is in the people
management business
right we're going to get into just
because it's what i do for a living of
how i think you can dramatically
increase
your
potential clients through digital
because it's there you know i've got a
lot of like i've said i've had several
friends and and acquaintances in this
business
if you're not running significant
linkedin ads right now for your business
you're making a massive mistake
i don't know how you plan on acquiring
new potential clients but i can promise
you
where linkedin is right now with ads and
creative
is
the most reminiscent thing to what i saw
with facebook in 2013
and it's a huge arbitrage and if you
leave this conference
with anything tangible for new business
generation i promise you it sits inside
of linkedin right now
you play in a b2b environment
as many of you know how many people here
consume content on linkedin occasionally
raise your hands high hi i want
everybody look around look around
and notice what i said i said how many
people here consume content on linkedin
as all of you know just looking at the
crowd
linkedin just five minutes ago aka six
years ago was just for recruiting
it has transformed into a content play
and that's why so many of you have
raised your hands
the ad targeting is bafflingly good
but it's expensive
because it's high value
so a lot of people hit me up they're
like you're pushing linkedin what are
they kicking you a bag in the back end
i'm like are you out of your [ __ ]
mind
gonna ruin my reputation for linkedin
give a [ __ ] about linkedin sorry i know
i'm supposed to not curse but i get
ridiculous about this one
i don't give a [ __ ] about any platform i
care about being historically correct so
my reputation is whole
what i know is that linkedin works
because go figure when you can target
the head of hr or a cfo or a direct job
description
and you know exactly who you sell to
every one of you
fully knows the title of the human
that has decided to give you money
now a lot of times that's just the ceo i
get it right
which is great then target ceos on
linkedin
and then tell them why you have a value
prop and what's great is when you tell
them you have a value prop that could be
in written form
that can be in video form
that could be in picture form
my biggest preference is you don't make
an infomercial
eighty percent of people do
they go directly into the right hook
it's all just trying to sell nobody here
wants to be sold you're gonna give
somebody thirteen hundredths of a second
on their video you know that it's going
in for the sale
meanwhile you're technically strong you
know the common headaches you literally
can step back and look
at the data let alone you know it off
the top of your head sitting here of the
consistent issues that people have so
instead of making it a sales pitch you
can make it an information
center
that looks like what if or what do you
do when
this happens
you then actually get consumption of the
video which actually then leads to
business because if you give good
content
it's not very hard for them to click
your face
and send you a message
so there there's there's
two core
worlds that i see for this group which
is
how well do people understand
the human variable of business
and how well do people understand the
current state
of how to get customers
that's it there is nothing else and i've
rinsed and repeated that for 25 years
and that's why all my businesses do
super well i started a client service
business in 2009
right
vaynermedia i
you know some of you how many people
here have grown up in a family business
raise your hands i just want to say so
the so the great thank you so much so
the 20 or 30 of you that just raised
your hands if you're the second
generation in a family business you know
exactly what i'm about to say i built my
dad's wine store for him
right i worked for 12 years
made
very little money because that's what
you do in a family business and at 34 i
had to leave even though i took my dad's
business from 3 to 60 million dollars i
had to leave and i started vaynermedia
in another company's conference room at
34 years old so when i put out all that
content to the kids on social about
patience i lived it i was 34
got grossly underpaid i wish
i didn't have a family business i wish i
was just an executive somewhere else i
would have got a bag
right
left had to start over started my
company when my brother graduated
college in buddy media's
um conference room
in columbus circle by this
above the starbucks there
and had to start a client service
business even though i never had a
client service business i was a wine
retailer
and
in
the first two years i really didn't want
to do it i was still too busy with wine
library and i wrote my first book crush
it and the garyvee thing started to
happen but then i saw the opportunity so
i went all in so i really started the
company in 2011
and so in a 10-year window
vaynermedia and now vaynerx because
there's eight companies under it has
gone from zero
to
286 million dollars in revenue
right
based on just the two simple things i'm
talking about which is
it's only about the human beings that
work for me
like my entire framework on the way i
look at my business is
the people that work for me
the customers
of my customers and then my customer
the number one mistake that a lot of my
friends make in this business model that
you're in is they value the customer
over their employee
it's a fundamental destroyer of your
upside
when you default every time to being on
the customer's side
regardless of the information when
you've gathered on what the situation is
at hand you've immediately limited the
upside of your business
incredibly foreign for a lot of people
but
so essential in the way that i see this
world
why i'm so hot on getting you good at
linkedin or anything else we talk about
later is if you have a strong funnel of
constant new business
it's going to give you the leverage to
have your employees back over your
customers back
hand in hand
hand in hand
i think that
i have a new book coming out in november
and
because it was covid and it was just
like a really good i was really in my
feelings when i wrote it
and i'm really excited about it and it's
called 12 and a half and it's really
about 13
human characteristics that i think
really lead to actual business success
because i think people are very confused
on who wins in business i think business
is completely misbranded i think people
think you have to have sharp elbows and
who's the most aggressive and who's the
most alpha and i actually genuinely
believe that soft skills like empathy
and kindness and accountability
and things of that nature are actually
the alpha skills that build very large
businesses but i called the book 12 and
a half because i want to go vulnerable
on you because it's
probably one of the more common things
i've seen
as a shortcoming and it was my greatest
shortcoming
because my father
was very candarous
you always knew where you stood with him
that was his favorite i'm like yeah you
stand hating you because you're mean
my dad was really great at candor
i on the other hand because my mom's not
and i was very bad at it
i
demonized it even more because the way
my dad delivered the candor was so
aggressive and negative i wasn't able to
separate the vehicle from what it was
so
what's really interesting about that was
it really was only about two or three or
four years ago where i started really
going into this place with me with all
my success
what was very obvious to me that
my number one job as a business owner is
to eliminate fear for my employees
number one
and the reason there was some fear in
the ecosystem
was because people didn't know where
they stood
because i would sit with who i thought
sucked
and i would try to coach up
i would try to rah-rah
i would try to team them up with
somebody who was awesome and hope for
some osmosis [ __ ] i was i was trying i
was trying everything
and then i'm sure and i can see by the
reaction of all of you you get to that
point where you just wake up and you're
like
yeah i'm firing sally today
and i would and and thursday this monday
and thursday i'd walk back and be like
sally have the best weekend ever
and monday i'm like sally can you come
in i'm like sally you got to go
and then i was the bad guy
because i wasn't able to deliver candor
and then sally go back to her desk and i
was like i saw gary say what's up to
sally super nice and give her a hug on
thursday i'm next yeah and and so i
thought about this a lot and this is
really hard to admit and it's like
that's why i'm so excited about this
book like i think for especially for the
people that follow me i'm old school
eastern european immigrant like my
garbage stays in my house
nobody knows anything about me i'm the
most public person you've never seen a
picture of my kids
they're 12 and 9.
like i'm in my own private life right
and that's the way i run my business too
my headaches are mine i'm what i share
to the world is the optimism is the good
thing it's not delusion there's nothing
but headaches being an entrepreneur all
of you know
everybody thinks this stuff is cool this
[ __ ] is exhausting
right this is 24 7 pressure
i wish
that when i come back next time around
i'm a number two
being a number two is epic
being in number two you get
a solid amount of the financial upside
and you get none
of this
feeling of there is nobody besides me
from the day i walked in my dad's store
full time when i was 22 to right now
i've been the single person responsible
to make payroll have never raised money
didn't even have a credit line
in my dad's store it's constant
on you
24 7.
and so
but being vulnerable and talking about
how weak i was at candor has been really
liberating for me
and i really hope helps some of you
because it really matters and the way i
brand it in the book some of you've
probably heard radical candor
be as that's gotten some momentum i
actually think that that's an excuse and
not radical kid i just think candor in
general has historically been an excuse
for people to be mean to people
i'm just being candarous you suck you
know like that kind of stuff
and so i frame it up as kind candor if
you walk into the situation and know
that you're delivering bad news
are you capable of finding the right
balance of tone
and in that candor can you make and i've
been practicing this hard for the last
24 months it's been game changing for my
business
and can that person leave and say wait a
minute gary's actually trying to give me
a chance to write this course
not
i'm going to now walk in fear 24 7. that
was a huge shift for me perspective wise
and i hope that helps even one of you
consider maybe having one kind candor
talk when you get back to the office it
matters
this is only about people
everything in the world is getting
commoditized
the only thing that's going to be left
is emotional intelligence we are mapping
everything else
this is a tech crew you guys know i
don't have to explain to you what's
going on in the world
what do you think is going on where do
you think ai's going where do you think
all of this is going this is all going
in one direction which is unless you
start really tapping into as an owner as
a leader where you sit on the emotional
graph of running a business that is
where all your financial upside sits and
leaving here with the mentality of
understanding you've got to focus on
your people
not your customer of course your
customer
but that's default i know you're
thinking about that
i know that you're trying to have
retention i know you've got all your
tricks and ideas and strategies and
ideas and hopes
of like how you keep that customer
what i want you to do is realize you're
playing defense that's amazing by the
way you have to play defense there's a
reason you play defense you do want to
do that that is good i just wanted to be
30 of your energy not 86.
once you start getting that framework
down you have a very different
opportunity to grow your business
when you're spending 35 percent of your
energy trying to get new customers in
the most progressive way for the money
you spend on it something interesting
happens when you spend 40 percent of
your time actually giving a crap about
every person that works for you for real
not kind of not saying it because it
sounds good but living it
a funny thing starts happening and so
getting that balance down in a monthly
retainer service based business with a
lot of customers average 3000 bucks a
month life and hoping to do seven 10 15
million dollars a year i promise you it
starts with your employees
it's next progressive marketing in a
2022 way and then third you can worry
about what you've actually spent most of
your time thinking about
that
is the framework so
i think
that's that's the framework i want to
start because i really want to go into q
a in detail of that framework
but i want to talk for a little bit more
and then i'll open up q a
on the second part which is getting
customers
i believe and this makes sense you know
uh i had a new cfo come in
uh four years ago and he's like this is
a mess
and i'm like break it down and so he's
breaking down he came from a big holding
company agency life right where he's
accustomed to you know having small
top-line growth and tons of profit it's
all defense and he sits and we break it
down for three hours
and i and then i said yeah but
we also grew 30 million dollars in
revenue
which was whatever percentage at the
time
and we kind of got into this joust very
good joust just because it was like
intellectual like business debate all
great vibes
and
finally i kind of like you know there's
nothing more fun than knowing what
you're talking about and playing mental
chess with somebody
it's the best feeling on earth right i
can see by the reaction like your
expertise right it's the best feeling
when you know the game
inside and out and you're playing it and
you like the other person it's nice so i
was in one of those moments
and finally like i kind of got him into
that you know there's that moment where
the person knows they walked into the
wrong spot
and he's there and he looks at me and
he's like
let me see this is what he said he goes
fine
yes
new revenues does solve everything
and and that's really why i want to
spend time on
marketing
you know i don't when i look around and
look at everybody's face
um
actually let me ask this question how
many people here plan on retiring within
10 years real quick not because you're
gonna crush it
and you're the messiah
but because
you're old and you're finished
raise your hands
raise it high raise it high own it own
it i see half hands go high
right so for the six of you
for the six of you
for the six of you
you know
a 10-year window
you know the world changes fast and slow
right the world changes fast and slow
but for the 98 of people in this room
when i think about how business people
make their business decisions in a b2b
environment
the evolution of the tactics needed in
marketing and sales over the next 10
years are staggering you know let's call
a spade a spade the majority of people
in here are sales organizations not
marketing organizations
you're in the sales business call call
when
the reality is is if you actually spent
25 hours on my very subtle quick mention
on linkedin and when i say 25 hours it's
the same 25 hours i spent in december
and january learning about nfts
right
if if you've seen what's happened in
that space
in 90 days i've made i've done 91
million dollars in revenue on my v
friends nft launch the first 51 million
i kept
which was in one week
the
the next 40
i've gotten a 10 royalty on every
transaction last night while i was
sleeping i made 246 thousand dollars on
the royalties of people selling my nfts
to each other
i didn't know what an nft was nine
months ago
but what i did when i understood
something was brewing is in the height
of my business
when i have a trillion things going on
while i'm trying to navigate nine
billion other businesses
i just spent 50 hours learning what nfts
were
so when i talk about
the thing i'm about to talk about i
never understand why i know 98 of you
are not going to spend 25 hours trying
to master linkedin ads i never
understand it
now i do understand it
it might be predicated on
lack of
revenue needs you just might be content
and complacent i don't even judge that i
think people have me very confused as a
character on the internet i don't think
you need to go crush it and go harder
and never sleep do you i don't give a
[ __ ]
i just don't like when people say
something and don't back it up
it drives me crazy when someone's like
i'm gonna be a billionaire i'm like
you're playing xbox
like like like i'm so confused right so
like here's my point and now now i know
i'm feeling something because i'm
standing up
if you knew how much admiration i have
for all of you right now it would touch
your heart let me tell you why
it's is today wednesday
thank you it is the wednesday thank you
it is the wednesday
it is the wednesday
of labor day weekend
it is september 1st today this is the
most checked out week
in the world
in the world this week
from america to shanghai definitely
europe those [ __ ] don't work
this week as we stand we're in the
middle of it the wednesday this is the
most checked out business week besides
christmas week in the world and you are
in this room listening
that tells me you're pop committed to
what you do
i i don't have a i mean i don't know if
you guys can see the goosebumps please
confirm this
you can't be here if you don't care
you cannot be sitting here if you're not
hungry you can't why would you be here
this is checked out week this jersey
shore life this is upstate like this is
checked out week so i'm sitting here
saying these people are here early on
this wednesday
so when i sit here and say i know i can
fundamentally fundamentally transform
every person's business here if they
just spent 25 hours
studying how to do linkedin ads properly
anybody can post an ad i'm talking good
i can dribble a basketball i'm not
[ __ ] lebron
please hear me on this please do 25
hours of linkedin homework
and start the way i did you know what my
first search was what is an nft enter
please figure this out because i'm
telling you
once you do and you get good at it
everything i actually want you to do
with people and the human stuff will
become a lot easier when you have a flow
of inbound customers i have empathy of
why you can't always be as sweet as i
want
it's because if you fire that client
because they're mean to your people you
might have a problem
i understand what it means to have to
pay the bills i get it
but i also know why
companies stay in the same spot their
whole lives this business that you have
owns you and you know it
and there's a way for it to not because
mine doesn't on the drive here
one of our biggest clients 12 million
dollar a year client
did something with our scope for next
year and handle a certain way and on the
ride here
i said to nick who runs that account i
said resign the business
you know what kind of leverage that is
you know how nice that feels
i want that for you
and i know how to get there and i've
seen it 100 times and i know exactly
what it doesn't look like
and it doesn't look like when you don't
know how to scale
marketing
sales
is just bad marketing
thank you
[Music]
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times
i also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon